from anti-trump to anti-american that is
the subject of tonight's waters words
political parties usually root against
each other when one party fails the
other returns to power but the Democrats
have invested so much in Trump's failure
that they're now rooting for America to
fail just so Trump takes a hit
here's bill maher I feel like the bottom
has to fall out at some point and by the
way I'm hoping for it because I think
one way you get rid of Trump is a
crashing economy so please bring on the
recession yeah sorry if that hurts
people but it's either roof for a
recession or you lose your democracy so
Bill Maher wants Americans to lose their
jobs and lose their money so the
president's approval rating goes down
that's sick it's easy for Marta root for
the economy to crash because he's
sitting on millions but at least he's
honest
most Democrats disguised their lack of
patriotism Pelosi is another one
hip-hip-hooray unemployment is down what
does that mean
to me in my life keep talking Nancy
you're costing the Democrats dearly and
after Trump returned from Singapore
securing a strong commitment to peace
the media attacked progress on the
peninsula a summit is not an
accomplishment for the American
president Brian it is a major
accomplishment for kim jeong-hoon
something else that our own care simmons
reported today and share with us at 4:00
p.m. is that both men are liars
he said kim jeong-hoon lies and he said
Donald Trump lies this is not a date
this is not going to work
this is not just lunch you know it's not
gonna work
I thought the Democrats were all about
dialogue and giving peace a chance
guess not but the worst was Chelsea
Handler who uncorked this whopper
already putin is giving Trump talking
points and actions to take to help
undermine the very country he is from we
have a domestic enemy running our
country pissing on all allies who shows
fealty only to Putin this is not America
this is Russia and then I hope kim
jeong-hoon eats Donald Trump so we have
the left calling the President of the
United States a domestic enemy comparing
him to a murderous dictator and rooting
against peace just because Trump is the
peacemaker and finally our friend joy
behar at the view putting the cherry on
top speaking about our stricter southern
border policy as Americans I mean I
don't know I guess people should not
tolerate this this is like this is like
Germany I mean come on people
well Germany back them not now so
America is now Nazi Germany it doesn't
get any worse than that